I am welcome to my talk I'm Francois
sheriff I'm co-founder and knowledge
engineer at treetop which is a small
start-up doing a ranking a
recommendation website we're not yet
launched and I will say a few words
about it
anyways and I will tell you about word
embeddings as a service many of you
probably have already heard about word
Tuvok so we're going to talk about it
and how we use it in production to do
recommendation and related stuff so I
will present a startup quickly and what
are words and bearings and how do we
implement a simple recommendation system
for three top categories so what is
three top three top is a ranking and
recommendation social media where users
go and enter the top three ranking in
the category of their choice
so the idea behind it is to get rid of
the star rating system by saying who
cares about three stars and less we are
only interested by about you know the
highest star rating and we're also not
really interested about reading through
a lot of reviews but we're really
interested in to finding the best stuff
right and that's why it for restaurants
that's valid for stuff on Amazon
that's valid for movies any category
really
so we're also oriented towards getting
recommendations from friends and so why
three because and you know why not 10 so
good question so the idea is actually if
you have more than three then you can
probably come up with a more refined
category more specialized category to
rank stuff so I will show you a few
examples now so all right okay here are
a few screens so you might not be able
to read here but it's a search for 1980s
vampire movies
and then finding ranking for on in the
middle screen for that category and then
on the right is picking up an item there
and you know getting some information
about that item so you can rank really
anything and everything so for example
here's the ranking about places that guy
Joseph rank is three top gyms for
students near the lower Eastside and you
know gave is Street up there and movie
three top movies about Wall Street and
here's the ranking by Michael my other
co-founder and then you know three top
foods named after people okay so really
you can go crazy and rank whatever you
like and so what you might see is there
are pictures and other information are
related with the items and so that's
what we're trying to do is to understand
what are the categories that are entered
by the users and what are the items in
this categories so the users just enter
free text categories by typing the
categories they type the items in this
category and and we try to understand
what is there inside okay so for that we
have a you know data engineering
pipeline where we're doing so NLP to
process the categories so we parse
categories we first developed our own
parser we are currently switching to
Spacey which is a great library if you
don't know it and you're doing an LP
it's a great Python library we're also
doing a named entity recognition and
linking with detecting location in
categories and so we have a knowledge
graph backed by an ontology and we're
trying so we have this atomization
pipeline that you know tastes what we
understand from the category takes the
items and then try to match those items
to an entity in the knowledge graph okay
and once we have that okay we have a
much richer data infrastructure to do
you know recommendation to present poor
information to the user as well
to do auto-completion to do various
tasks so here we're examples so movies
about Wall Street is a category foods
named after people yeah so it can be
either you type it yourself or you get
it from a friend and then you will react
right so a friend of yours share that
category share this ranking and you will
say oh my three top movies about Wall
Street is actually not that so Yuri rank
so that's you know you can agree here or
rewrite the thing and so in that case
you won't type the category every new
category makes it in the system yeah
yeah so you will see we're not yet
Lounge formally so we're hoping for
thousands and thousands yes so here is a
you know an illustration of the what I
was talking about we have this knowledge
graph in the middle and we're by these
pipelines we're relating items and
categories to the knowledge are four
categories we try to identify what the
main concept for the category is and
relate that to the knowledge graph and
then through it relate items to various
you know api's so we use dbpedia we use
wiki data you know Yelp four places etc
etc okay so now let's go to the matter
of the talk so what we wanted was a
recommendation and a simple
recommendation engine that I it would be
more accurate to call a related engine
so when you're in a category page or on
a ranking page it will recommend your
related categories the problem is
look at those impressive figures we we
have 300 users 2100 rankings and 1300
categories so doing collaborative
filtering on that would not and
especially because of the open-ended the
thing of the system we have categories
in you know a lot of different spaces
or topics and so collaborative filtering
wouldn't work and so yeah big data so so
we heard about our word too vague and so
we you know gave it a try and it's
something that worked pretty well that
we are pretty happy with and so I will
present you how we develop that
recommendation engine and how we're
using it in production so who hasn't
heard about we're two back here a few
not many okay all right so word to back
is an implementation it's an algorithm
to realize a world embedding and word
embeddings allowed to represent words in
a high dimensional space in a way that
the words appearing in the same context
in the training corpus will be close in
that space at the end so what I'm saying
high dimensional it's not that high
dimensional it's in the hundreds of
dimensions and yeah that's it so a few
quick comparison so compared to bag of
words the dimensionality is low and
constant with regard to the vocabulary
size so you set up the number of
dimensions you want in your word vectors
prior to the training and the dimension
will remain constant and then depending
on the training algorithm you're using
you will get partially learned models
giving you partially good results we
which can be good if you want to
experiment with different corpuses for
example compared to topic modeling I say
better granularity because the base
element is the world but there really
that's what I wrote but really it's it's
a different thing you're studying you're
studying so in both cases you have a
corpus but in one case you were studying
what are the documents what is the
meaning of a specific document in a
corpus for fall in the corpus for topic
modeling while here we're really
studying what is the meaning of the
words in my corpus okay so it's a
different granularity
something to mention is that there are
extensions to were too vague that learn
phrases so that our documents so that
take into consideration the order of the
words okay in sentences we're not there
yet so I will not talk about it so what
are word embedding models good at
they're good at modeling similarity
between words in a continuous manner so
similarity between tomato and beefsteak
will be lower than the similarity billon
an apple and a tomato which will be
lower than a similarity between a pear
and an apple okay and then you can take
your vectors and then do algebraic
operations on this word vector so you
know the vector of Paris minus the
vector of friends will be similar to the
vector of in minus the vector of Germany
and I will now show some examples
directly using so the most popular
library on in Python which is the Jensen
library that has an efficient
implementation of the training algorithm
for word Tuvok so we're using here glove
model so it wasn't trained with Jensen
and we're too vague but with another
training algorithm called glove so we're
reusing this pre trained model very
easily by loading it into the from the
Jensen library and then we are querying
that by asking the most similar words
for the word Python and we've got the
list here so I can read photos we can
see I have Monty PHP Perl please leaper
Ruby Spamalot JavaScript reticulated and
monkey so for those who know Monty
Python this should be pretty clear so
some other examples now I will combine
two words Python and programming which
will do an average on the vectors and
then build that virtual vector and try
to get the closest vector to that
virtual vector and I get purse
scripting scripts PHP and language okay
so here is an application this
application okay that's very
straightforward another example if I do
Python in venomous then I get results in
the snakes and spider domain okay all
right and so now the most classical
example that you will find on every blog
and every paper in the literature this
is the analogy example so man is - King
what woman is 2x and ask the question
and so we can do that very easily as
well and I see that indeed the result is
Queen and but the other results also
interested so monarch which is like a
non-gendered version of king and queen
and throne we can also be understood in
that same context so now how about
training a model so it is very easy once
you have a clean corpus given the
libraries and tools that are available
in Python there are very good tutorials
on Jensen there was a also talk last
year at PI data in Berlin about ready
memory rec who is the author of Jensen
and especially do the interesting part
is the optimization insight on that make
it very efficient there is also a
library for a glove which is more
experimental but there are also some
interesting pull requests that you can
check that make it actually pretty
efficient so to tell more about the
implementation specifics the training
time for a 1.9 billion words corpus
which start to be interesting is a tower
on 8th Prague and at 8 read to learn 600
dimension model the memory requirement
in
Jennsen is linear with regard to the
number of dimensions and the size of the
vocabulary the glove implementation is
faster but as the original
implementation python implementation as
quadratic memory size but again there
are some poor request for optimizations
in here so glove has that night feels
nice feature that if you stop the
training you already have some partially
partially good results compared to word
too vague that requires that you
complete the training in order to get
some good results something to mention
again is that Ingenium you can always
you can keep training a model so if your
corpus your base corpus evolves over
time you can always refine your model by
adding more sentences to your to your
model so that's a nice feature one good
thing to know the in general the bigger
your original corpus is the more the
better results you will get
independently on the tasks you are doing
so if you throw more data into your
model you will get good results so you
will yeah the thing so you would say oh
okay then I take the biggest model that
was you know trained by the author of
glove or were too vague and I'll be fine
so what you might want is to actually
learn things about your corpus and in
that case then you rather you know train
your model on your corpus so or if you
wanna for example compare two different
parts of your corpus
I see how the vocabulary the meaning of
words change in that case you'd rather
go and train your model yourself so in
our case because of the you know very
open-ended tasks we're having we're
reusing a corpus from glove so we
we did you know we compare different
train models and we put those on get up
here you can check there's a list of
different models with a lots of
different columns there that we cannot
see that tell you what was the training
algorithm and etcetera so if you are
interested we are currently using this
common crawl for two billion words
corpus with 300 dimensions that give
good results so when we did not try that
sorry this bigger 800 billion words oops
corpus yet okay so now we've got our
model that is trained already and we
want to do recommendations for our
categories so it's pretty
straightforward what we're doing is
we're taking the words appearing in the
categories and then we combine the
vectors to get a new vector that would
be a category vector and then we do that
for every category on our on the website
and we get this category space and then
now we we do we ask for most similar
categories in this space so what are the
closest categories around the category
okay yep
yeah yeah we'll we're coming to that
yeah so what we we try different
techniques so we try to keep only the
main noun or main on phrase in a
category but at the end what works well
for us is to keep everything that is not
block words stop words basically Sundown
verbs adjectives those are post tags so
noun plural noun adjective yeah I may
not be able to give them the n ng BN is
in case we detect a name entity from
dbpedia for example so we have extended
that not canonical all right so then we
put those vectors in a category space as
I said and getting the similarity
between two categories is just doing a
dot product between the two category
vectors so let's look at some examples
this one doesn't display very well by
this blue color beers that come in a can
and we get as a result I can as a result
we get Belgian Trappist beers Belgium
beer caffeine NYC dark has tell me
cocktails in the NYC so you know given
the amount of categories that we have
this this is really good results what is
very interesting is so dark and stormy
cocktails in NYC we know which is
semantically somewhat related to blue
color beers because it's about drinks
but as you can see none of the words are
the same right so that's one of the good
features is that every find synonyms and
anymore yeah
it's just a dot product and not like a
cosine similarities because the vectors
already normalized correct yes yes they
are normalized yeah yeah
another example Italian restaurants in
NYC so Italian restaurants in New York
restaurants in NYC NYC Mexican
restaurants etc etc and finally Coen
Brothers movies we get Quentin Tarantino
movies Martin Scorsese move films movies
start starring creepy children etc etc
so we have some funny categories I
invite you to check it out free table
comm yeah and again here you know Coen
brother movies and Martin Scorsese films
you know films and movies are seen on it
you might you know using other
techniques you mean you know like
wordnet you might find that they are in
the same scene set etc but it's really
it really is a much simpler way of doing
similarity so we're using the common
crawl for two billion words so common
crawl is a for the does we don't know is
a partial crawl of the web it's a you
know an open data a for to try to
provide web crawls that can lead to
search engines like DuckDuckGo for
example is based on the common crawl so
we have words coming from everywhere
what a good thing about this corpus as
well is it contains also a lot of bad
data like words containing spelling
mistakes things like lol or lol or so
all these kind of funny words you find
on the on the web and this is
interesting because that's what our
users do you know they enter words and
but they are in the corpus so that's
interesting
so what is taking six gigs of memory is
the word to vac model that we learned
were too vague model that was the number
of words in the corpus now I think about
the size yeah yeah yeah so yeah so we're
using our app our site is in Django
we're using celery and you know until
recently we had salary and Django
working on the same easy to micro
instance so you know there's no way we
can allocate all that memory for our
service so that's when we decided to
build an API for this word embedding
that we could query and then would
return us I'm sorry if we don't see the
bottom of the slide so we can query that
and it returns us the the so we have
different methods there so it's a simple
flash server that you know you access
were like similarity between word one
and word - and similarity if you want
different words we have a model keywords
sorry we have a model keyword that will
return you the model for a word and it's
easy to set up you just pass know if you
can see it here you just pass the the
model an argument and then you get a
server providing you the word - back
model are we using
or Tyvek as is implemented in jensen yep
oh that's true that's just so I what a
service I you know it doesn't cost much
to provide that as well for you know
before publishing that you know it was
it makes it easier for people I guess so
that's our architecture I won't talk a
lot about it just so we have this here
this word vector space word similarity
service you know if you're interested I
can tell you more you know basically
there's django instances salary workers
well in the amazon Reaume okay
so now we have a few categories in the
space but we're one thing we're planning
to do is to pre generate a lot of
categories to make it even better
like even easier for the users having
more like autocomplete features so so
that will have that will make the the
size of the category space itself
increased so for our thousand categories
we have a two megabyte category space
right so I know it might be confusing
here right on one side there's the word
Tuvok word model that we're using to
build a category model okay
so there's two different things and so
that category model is currently kind of
small so we have it in memory in each in
each worker but it might get bigger so
what we're doing we're so storing the
category vectors in the sequel database
as a django object as part of the
category a django object for that we
we're serializing the number vector as a
base
for anchoring and I'd be glad to have
feedback on that cause I don't know how
where we can discuss that later a big
lie
I don't have a much argumentation for
that so we're so we're defining this
vector property on the category model
with a get and a set that will you know
encode and decode at the vector when we
need it and so we we can get the I I
guess that there's no numpy array in my
sequel right to store it as a string
which is what we're doing okay okay so
all right so we're doing that and then
the second thing that we're doing in
order to not query the database each
time we are using memcache to to cache
that category space and when so we have
each vector cache with its own key and
then the indexes for the model cache
with one key for each index okay so that
allows us to so yeah okay
so and now when we update each process
so each process has its own copy of the
vector space and then whenever a new
category is added the the vector cache
is updated and signals signal to the
processes the the workers to reload from
the space okay ten minutes all right
so this is a work in progress so I was
telling you we're planning to add these
hundreds of thousands of categories and
now this category space will become
large
we cannot anymore tolerate having each
worker having is copy of the space
similar thing that happened with the
original model so my guess is that we
will put that on a server again and have
that as a service and then do some
caching at various legal not to to have
to query that service too much
now what we're also planning to do is to
include entity vectors so to learn
entities vectors so that so currently if
you have New York City you have three
words New York and city and each have
their own context and combining them is
not as good as having one entity New
York City that is learned as it in the
corpus okay so there are techniques to
do that it's a bit more pragmatic to do
that at large scale but we're we are
going to try that another thing we're
planning to do is to train a specialized
corpus now using so by scrapping a lot
of treetops like best things like
categories all over the web and to train
a corpus based on that and also train a
phrase to work or document to make a
model on these categories that remember
the orders the order of the world and a
last thing that I didn't mention is that
once the category space become large
getting the similarity becomes slow and
so I've heard about the annoy library
that allows to do approximate finding up
approximate similarity in in the space
and we're also planning to to try that I
put some few resources so linked to
various blog posts that I find
interesting on the topics on the topic
and as well a few academic papers
especially
I recommend you the papers from Levy and
Levi and Goldberg on that topic they
they are not authors of were too vague
nor globe but they discuss their
relationship and it's been very
interesting that's it thank you we do
mean a simple mean on the vectors not
much I I read that there are different
possibilities you can add vectors simply
you could even concatenate vectors but
you have the problem that then different
categories will have different size so
it doesn't help really but yes some or
mean is what I saw what sorry yeah how
do we clean up the categories that
people are enter yeah okay yeah we're do
we're doing a little cleanup and but we
still have a way to go so to correct
typos we're using actually Google
spelling a Google spell checker we title
casing categories we're removing dots
that kind of thing
nothing fancy sorry that was the
question before
yes so Jensen actually has a phrase to
vague talk to back implementation yes it
is in Jensen oh no so for models no so
surprisingly I don't know about any
model that is trained with the dog to
vague and I'd be glad if anyone knows
about it I'd like to try that yeah they
know they only have a word yeah so in
the original word Tuvok implementation
from Google there's this thing where you
can you can do multiple passes and
there's a like account of how frequently
words are co-located and you by setting
a trestle with you will do a second pass
and consider those as an entity and it
will so but this is kind of fake right
it's purely statistical so I guess it
kind of work so that that's one first
approach a second approach which is
which is you know much more problematic
I would say is to first do some named
entity recognition on your corpus and
then tag those entities and then do
their learning the problem is if you are
in you know multiple tens of billions of
words it starts to be very expensive and
so to do the named entity recognition
yeah
which lane every slide 30 is there any
can I talk as well okay if there's any
other question I can yep no I haven't to
be honest I I know so you can download
the Google corpus the Google News pre
train model and you see there are named
entities there and yeah I mean I didn't
extensively tested it but you know New
York City is their cities are their
famous persons are there yeah there's
also a free base model that is trained
on freebase entities there so that might
be also something to consider and there
are various like this is a you know
famous hype topic in NLP and people are
trying a lot of various things so it's
kind of hard to follow but I know the
dbpedia people are working on training
dbpedia vectors so that correspond to
topics or Wikipedia
you know topics yeah so we're using
Wikipedia categories and then based on
our ontology we define in the ontology
especially for places we define a lot of
kind of types like for example we have
all sorts of restaurants Italian
restaurant and pizzeria
we have Brazilian restaurant you know
also and we will combine that with
cities okay so
three top Italian restaurants in New
York three top Italian restaurants in
the West Village three top aquariums in
Chicago you know so just extensive
generations or generation of categories
like this is the speed okay can I go
faster I'm good okay all right thank you